en dr weiss bonsoir
bonsoir merci d'être là on voit de
l'inquiétude d'un peu partout dans le
monde plusieurs pays qui ont refermé la
frontière qui ont rehaussé les mesures
est-ce qu'on a raison de s'inquiéter au
teint de ce nouveau variant
écouter on a un peu raison parce qu'on a
appris de nos erreurs passées et donc on
voit quelque chose de nouveau et énergie
quelque part il faut tout de suite
prendre des mesures pour essayer de le
contenir le plus possible mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que vous savez
l'afrique du sud il ya déjà un variant
qui a émergé la règle de sud c'est un
pays propice à l'émergence des variantes
à cause de la population la densité à
cause des conditions sociaux et
sanitaires à l'occasion qui peuvent ne
pas être très bonne et ce variant là
surtout immergé dans la province du
gauteng qui est la province de herat
netbook donc la plus grande ville en
afrique du sud et se maria à aussi
déplacé en partie le variante delta en
termes si vous voulez d'efficacité donc
ce qui montre que cet invariant qui est
capable d'être très transmissible
s'est dit préoccupé par ce nouveau
variant tout à fait et en plus de ça ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que cet
invariant qui se propage en afrique du
sud à une période de l'année où
théoriquement étant dans l'hémisphère
sud l'afrique du sud est en train de
sortir si vous voulez de leur printemps
pour rentrer dans leur était alors que
nous nous sortons de notre automne pour
entrer dans notre hiver donc c'est pas
la saison des virus respiratoires en
théorie ils sont presque à notre été
alors ils devraient dans leur période
d'accalmie on voit que ce virus là est
en train de se propager ce virus-là a
probablement émerger dans chez des gens
qui sont immunodéficients vous savez que
l'afrique du sud est un pays où il ya
beaucoup de patients atteints du vih pas
tous sont traités et souvent les
patients vih qui peuvent être porteurs
de ce genre de virus on le sait avec
d'autres virus peuvent excrété le virus
pendant de très longues périodes de
temps ce qui permet au virus d'acquérir
un certain nombre de mutations est
d'arriver à un virus qui est très
changeant donc invariants invariance
navires us qui a eu beaucoup de
mutations et celui ci a à peu près la
particularité d'avoir une trentaine de
mutation
notamment à des sites qui sont
importants pour s'attacher sur les
cellules humaines doux si vous voulez
l'inquiétude qui peut avoir au niveau
des différents organismes sur la planète
il semble se propager rapidement c'est
la première fois depuis de temps qu'on
parle autant d'un nouveau variant
l'autre inquiétude qu'on a c'est de
savoir est-ce qu'il est résistant aux
vaccins qu'on a réussi à développer
qu'on a maintenant alors oui c'est en
réalité la grande inquiétude on ne sait
pas encore on n'a pas de données
précises on va voir comment les choses
vont évoluer il ya quand même des gens
en afrique du sud qui ont reçu
différents vaccins beaucoup de vaccins
d'astrazeneca entre autres mais aussi
certains vaccins à arn et on va voir
comment les gens vaccinés avec ses
différents vaccins là vont être protégés
contre ce virus
ce qui est aussi important de savoir
c'est que le génie est un peu sorti de
la bouteille là parce que sachant que le
vaccin le virus est en afrique du sud
sachant qu'il ya plusieurs pays
africains d'afrique australe qui sont
déjà touchés et sachant que beaucoup de
pays africains n'ont pas les capacités
de détecter ces variants rapidement il
est fort possible que beaucoup d'autres
pays africains et déjà ce variant
présents sur le territoire le fait que
plusieurs pays du moyen-orient qu'en
belgique possiblement grande bretagne on
est déjà détecté ce variant également
savait que la belgique est un pays qui a
beaucoup de liens avec le congo parce
que c'était la république démocratique
du congo est donc à ce moment là est ce
que le variant serait déjà présents dans
ce pays là qui est un géant
démographique de l'afrique et qui
pourrait donc être à ce moment là une
zone de propagation importante
question pour l'instant bon au point de
presse cet après midi le ministre de la
santé du clos disait que bon pour
l'instant officiellement il n'y a pas de
cas recensé au canada mais est ce que le
variant pourrait déjà être présent ici
une possibilité je pense que personne ne
peut l'écarter mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut paniquer au contraire je
pense qu'ils c'est pour ça que c'est
important d'avoir des mesures de
surveillance au niveau des différents
virus donc on continue de faire de la
surveillance génétique si vous roulez
l'empreinte de ces virus là pour savoir
si ces virus là arrivent dans notre
environnement ou pas et c'est que c'est
très important parce que ça va nous
permettre ce système d'un r de détecter
de nouveaux variants qui pourrait
devenir potentiellement problématiques
et quand je dis problématique ça veut
dire problématique sur l'efficacité des
vaccins
oui voilà c'est ça et peut-être aussi
sur les médicaments qu'on est en train
de développer chez phase honnêtement oui
alors les médicaments c'est moins un
problème parce que souvent ce médicament
là risque d'avoir un peu plus
d'efficacité par contre il ya des
thérapies qu'on appelle les anticorps
monoclonaux donc des mythes vous savez
ces médicaments injectables qu'on donne
aux gens malades pour à les neutraliser
en quelque sorte de virus est comme une
sorte de vaccins mais une béquille
temporaire et à ce moment là ces
anticorps monoclonaux qui sont
disponible et commercialisée
actuellement très utiles pour réduire la
maladie sévère chez des gens qui sont
pas hospitalisés n'est qu'un des
facteurs de risque si ce match si ce
virus là se propage de façon important
dans notre environnement en effet ces
molécules hla pourrait devenir moins
efficace mais je vous dirais le legrand
qui est la grande question est pour
l'instant on ne le sait pas
c'est ce que les vaccins vont continuer
à garder leur efficacité ce qui est
encourageant c'est qu'en dépit d'avoir
vu toutes ces mutations avec vous savez
vous rappelez bien sûr le virus delta
mais le virus alpha avant et d'autres
variant les vaccins dans les vaccins à
rl ce qu'on a beaucoup utilisé au canada
que ce soit moderna aufhaeuser sont des
vaccins qui adapte tiennent bien la
route et continue de garder leur
efficacité espérons que ce soit la même
chose dans ce cas ci c'est ce qu'on va
savoir donc au cours des prochaines
semaines j'imagine avec les études qui
sont sûrement déjà en cours ou sur le
point de l'être oui tout à fait donc on
va prendre au moins quelques semaines
avant de savoir qu'est ce qui va se
passer il va falloir aussi surtout en
europe en europe vous savez qu'ils
connaissent une activité très intense du
virus actuellement il va falloir qu'ils
s'assurent qu'ils aient pas plus de deux
ses souches là qui ont débarqué dans
leur environnement et à là aussi on
verra s'il ya une propagation importante
de cette souche là mais vous savez pour
un virus tout ça invariants c'est tout à
fait normal et naturel c'est une
adaptation du virus à son environnement
et on va en voir d'autres des comme ça
qu'est ce que vous pensez des mesures
qui ont été annoncées par ottawa
aujourd'hui en train de fermer les
frontières aux voyageurs provenant des
sept pays de l'afrique australe donc
vraiment de la région de l'afrique du
sud est-ce que c'est suffisant bon camp
qui a été détectée également belgique
est ce qu'on devrait
fermer la porte à davantage de pays ou
rehausser nos mesures ici non je pense
qu'on a le système qui a été annoncé et
un bon système on peut se réjouir de la
vitesse de réponse ont tiré du
gouvernement fédéral à mettre en place
ces mesures je pense que ça démontre
qu'il ya une évolution dans la pensée de
la façon dont on approche les choses
quand on se compare à ce qui se passait
au début de la pandémie alors d'un
frontières n'étaient pas fermées on a
beaucoup appris et très rapidement on a
mis en place des mesures pour justement
limiter la propagation potentielle de ce
genre de virus l'ap le fait d'avoir
aussi des systèmes dans différentes
provinces de surveillance au point de
vue génétique des différents virus qui
circule au canada sont des systèmes d'
alerte si vous voulez nous permettre
aussi de faire un suivi quasi en
live on dira l'a donc de fait de façon
continue
tout à fait de l'émergence de deux de
ses cds russie là dans votre
environnement donc je vous dirais qu'au
canada on a quand même un bon système de
surveillance non au niveau de la
structure globale que ce soit au niveau
fédéral ou au niveau des provinces et
des sénateurs venus rapidement oui c'est
ça ils sont intervenus rapidement ça va
possiblement à aider mais en même temps
doctoresse en terminant le tout ça ça
nous ramène à l'importance de réduire
les inégalités vaccinale entre les pays
finalement pour éviter qu'il y ait tant
d'autres mutations importantes
oui mais il ya d'autres défis par
rapport à ça il ya tout le défi de la
logistique et l'acceptabilité
aujourd'hui des vaccins dans certains
pays où les populations ne veulent pas
forcément être vaccinés donc il ya
énormément de défis c'est pas juste
d'envoyer des vaccins dans certains pays
c'est aussi le fait qu'ils puissent être
adéquatement distribués et que les
populations soient prêtes à les recevoir
parce que des pays où les gens ne sont
pas très enclins à vouloir se faire
vacciner
et quand vous avez vu adac l'immense
majorité des variants vient de pays on a
parlé du variant indien on a parlé du
variant sud africain du variant
brésilien donc des pays souvent vous
avez de très gros poids démographique
vous avez des zones aussi où il ya des
problèmes ne socio sanitaire alors on
peut malheureusement se dire que dans la
grande ville de johannesbourg de
plusieurs millions d'habitants et dans
les townships de johannesburg
il y à une joue dirait une des
conditions propices à l'émergence de ces
variants dans des populations pas
vaccinés ou il ya une densité
démographique très élevé et aussi où il
ya des patients qui sont atteints par
exemple du vih pas traiter et qui fait
que vous avez une propension une
facilité pour ses variantes d'émerger
dans ce conte armé d'un scientifique
certainement qui se penche sur tout ça
est présentement à travers le monde est
en quart vince merci infiniment d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir ça me fait plaisir
l'arrêt